мы потеряли три миллиона 200 тысяч
долларов
наверное за другим буду заниматься но
вот этот шоколад по лицу продал ниже под
ниже рынка на 20 процентов на 20 или 30
процентов и еще и конверт но это за на
520 сейчас на данный момент курс и
спасибо я ничего переживем не счет 1 2
молодые приспособить по статистике чем
хуже ситуация в стране в государстве
больше снимается комедий все крис я
прохожу сейчас впервые ведь если у вас
есть опыт дата первый кризис второй
кристалл пандемии мы проходим до 9
все-таки а крис выдать его прикольно
новая задача то есть человек
переоценивать свои возможности и
недооценивает угрозы риск крылья такому
так он на самом деле крис и тони это
кризис вот отсюда и медленно твоей жены
будет самым вытягивать весов
[музыка]
добрый день друзья и мы начинаем наш
очередной выпуск нашего game бы подкаста
и до того как мы приступим я хотел бы
сначала конечно обратиться к зрителям мы
снимаем game бы подкаст в начале месяца
рамадан хотел бы поздравить всех
верующих мусульман с этим святым
праздником орозо воронка властный
вкратце скажу напомню вам я в каждой
передаче ночная именно с этого
напоминание что значит game бы подкаст
потому что поступает очень много
вопросов что такое гемба гемба этот
термин из японской кайзен философии
который обозначает место где создается
ценность для клиента то есть вот если
брать производственную цепочку
производственную линию там например в
компании тойота то там где создается
ценность для потребителя то место
называется гемба и второе значение и the
game по где место где решаются проблемой
то есть смысл такой в кайзен философии
есть и где-то на производстве возникла
проблема по начальник должен поднять
свою задницу выйти со своего кабинета
прийти на точку где возникла проблема
обсудить там с теми людьми которые
работают там и принять решение там то
есть гемба это место возникновения
проблемы и место обсуждения и решения
этой проблемой поэтому когда мы создали
гемба подкаста смысл был такой что мы
будем обсуждать насущные важные проблемы
которые беспокоит и волнует общество
будем обсуждать при этом напомню ещё
такой момент что это не место где
собираются эксперты для того чтобы
давать свое экспертное заключение
это как раз таки место где собираются
обычные люди бизнесмены с разных сфер
артисты журналисты
там бизнесмены простые люди и мы
обсуждаем возникшую ситуацию
свое мнение кто что предпринимает как
эта ситуация сказалось на их жизни и так
далее так далее но такие своеобразные
между между собой ские так сказать
разговоры
теперь сразу забегая вперед скажу
сегодняшней передачи должна была
участвовать с нами гульнара башке нова
это на тот случай если кто-то будет
обвинять нас в том что
среди нас нет у женщин мы добросовестно
пригласили гульнара перепутал акация
дату и она думала что съемки будет 5
апреля поэтому у нас такая накладочка
поэтому у нас сегодня пятеро мужчин
я думаю мы справимся
постараемся справиться без женщин
сегодня итак по традиции я предоставляю
слово слева направо для того чтобы
участники и гости представили себя слева
от меня
меня зовут планш онлайн
предприниматель у нас сфера образования
инфобизнес
access to page хотя 4 детей
города джамбул по 1
всем добрый вечер меня зовут амир
я занимаюсь fashion ритейла
сеть магазинов одежды гайсина я отец
пятерых детей чуть переплюнул
вот
[музыка]
отлично влад бижанов предприниматели
эксперт сфере личного бренда и
основатель рекламного компания декад
сегодня буду по могу рассказать что
нужно делать экспертом фрилансером
сегодня вот в такое непростое время
добрый день меня зовут санжар мади актер
режиссер и продюсер начинающий бизнесмен
отец пока одного ребенка так классно это
к у нас вы видите такой состав здесь не
все бизнесмены но самое главное что я
вообще считаю что правильно
как на западе каждый человек должен
думать как бизнес мы не обязательно быть
бизнесменом но думать надо как бизнесмен
на западе каждый врач знает бюджет
операции каждый зная врач знает сколько
стоит операция сколько стоит его
оборудования сколько себестоимость
зарплата расходы и доходы
учет финансов и так далее и каждый
учитель каждый госслужащие то знает к
сожалению в наших странах считается что
управление финансами и бизнес это сфера
бизнесменов а все остальные должен
заниматься только творчеством вот маги
как раз сегодня ты говоришь начинающий
бизнесмен это очень хорошо это очень
хорошо что ты вот какие режиссер ты уже
вынужден буш и как продюсер вынужден
считать доходы расходы и спонсоров или
там рекламы и так далее да давайте
сегодня такая тема сегодняшняя тема
понятна мы не можем далеко отойти от той
ситуации которая происходит не то что
далеко отойти более того мы как раз таки
хотим обсудить самую актуальную тему
сейчас у нас актуальная тема в прошлом
месяце если это была война россии с
украиной то в этом месяце на первое
место выходит тема аня кризис кризис и
антикризисное мышление антикризисное
поведения как этот кризис сказывается на
жизни каждого из нас что мы делаем что
собираемся предпринимать что мы думаем
произойдет дальше ну и так далее так
далее поэтому первый вопрос
кризис насколько вы
почувствовали кризис как он на вас
сказался какие негативные последствия
уже или пока это на уровне слов
давайте сначала вот с этого как кризис
сказался на сдаваться короче он
докатился или нет вот это или это просто
только словам и бывает и такое все друг
друга пугаем твоим кризиса никто еще не
почувствую конечно
сферы образования как я думаю в россии и
казахстане у нас все резко
[музыка]
резко снизился уровень на одобрение
расточку то поможет этот бизнес построен
на рассрочки чеки высокие и
у нас мы работаем с панками от они
сейчас перестали выдавать рассрочки
соответственно то есть банки переставали
перестали выдавать займы для обучения
для обучения беспроцентную рассрочку
это думаю видно у нас конечно тоже
выспаться на пару до 90 даже многие томи
игроки уже очень сложно продавать своего
слугу соответственно они наверное
почувствовали и наш сектор почувствовал
потому что ее еще надо понимать что
именно образование тоже была такая
история это история была про легкие
деньги пришел там что рассказал этом
заработал деньги но я бы скорее не про
образования этого больше такие как даже
затруднительно было я назвал это слово
шуме нами шума театр шум если бы одного
какую-то суету шум под соусом
образования и ну как бы да но чувствуем
у нас пошли пошли нам темизация с
первого дня это делаем но я цапа
чувствуют
другие игроки тоже час и очень сильно
чувствует кто знаком татьяна этот кошмар
и говорили что половина верно того что
поэтому вначале было
настроение было то есть камни у меня был
договорились моя подруга цель записать
подкаст и утром на говорить сегодня не
будет
видео там что-то случилось потом я
спрашиваю а почему почему оказались как
хорошая тема была она говорит что я
думала чужого путин уже пустит на кнопку
и вы летите на война а смысл писать
отказ
я понимаю что примерно плюс минус вот
такая жизнь потому что любом случае
образование то про будущее образования
храня надежду а когда человека у
человека нет он одежда должен выглядеть
паника или вся стратегия уходит на
покупку сахара это лист бумагу и
соответственно к сожалению я думаю в за
март продажа туалет туалет и бумага
наверно раза что что продать это это
много раза что превысило наверно продажи
онлайн-курсов поэтому да мы
почувствовали примерно как на тебе
сказался кризис ты как-то негативно
сказался на тебе на твоем бизнесе на на
самом деле я думаю кризис мы первые одни
из первых почувствовали потому что мы
являемся импортерами у нас одежда мы
продаем одежду и вот этот подскоки
доллара мы сразу почувствовали первые и
сейчас что мы предприняли чтобы вот
когда нивелировать вот эти вот колебания
доллара
мы сейчас решили
переехать в стамбул
как бы я я считаю что самое сейчас самое
время внедрять внедрять казнен
технологии оптимизировать полностью
бизнес переходить с режима важно мир до
этого дойдем что делать ты сейчас скажи
как кризисы в чем на тебе вот
сказался негативно а ну вот
первое то что повлияло это вот
девальвация то что то что доллар сколько
ну вот это очень сильно на нас повлияло
и второе то есть у вас выручка в тенге
да товар вы импортируете из-за этого
царства выросла на и ещё один момент мы
очень как бы заметили сейчас что
покупатели стали покупать меньше в том
плане что они начинали над раньше если
покупали за одну покупку могли сделать 2
3 то есть в одном чеке две-три вещи то
сейчас это мы видим что они покупают
только одну вещь то есть они стараются
как бы сэкономить где-то там ужаться это
очень сильно повлияло на покупательскую
способна это получается не из-за того
что у них доходы упали огрызка не упали
же это больше психологический какой-то
страх появился до этого так вот это мы
очень как бы заметили сразу
такие вот явления вот по конвертации ты
говорил что
закупил долларов по 520
личной трагедии ли я в это я вообще как
бы проанализируют ситуацию считаю что в
кризис не нужно делать никаких таких
резких шагов нужно просто ожидать и
сидеть как бы это такая история у нас
было был было этот зум конференция и
была такая стратегия что вот надо там
скупать то есть продавать все свои
активы если у тебя есть покупатель ниже
20 процентов на следующий день я пошел и
сразу как бы ну рода продал ниже ниже
рынка за на 20 процентов на 20 или 30
процентов и еще и конверт ну это на 520
сейчас на данный момент курс 470 ну там
нормально и так потерял
но это вопрос
долгосрочной перспективе это не поделив
краткосрочной до потери на самом деле то
что о чем-то мир говорит это мои
рекомендации я говорил продавать активы
и
покупать доллары а здесь очень важно
такой момент я наверно тогда неправильно
указал ты абсолютно правильно вот вещи
из своего опыта за тебя уже и зато свой
опыт и своего опыта что не надо делать
резких движений вообще надо делать
лесенку я-то исходила из своему позиции
я как делаю я все время по мере
поступления ручки конвертирую я
convertilla и по 460 по 4 7 по 500 по
515 потом потом 500 с чем-то опять 494
сорт у меня получается все это время вот
так конвертируем и в результате средняя
средний курс такой более-менее от им
получается взяла одним куском взял и все
сконвертировал но это краткосрочная
ошибка долгосрочном это ошибкой не будет
потому что я сто процентов уверен но 99
процентов что деньги точно не будут
укрепляться против доллара также как и
рубль не бутылку укрепляться против
доллара и
в этом плане я думаю долгосрочно не не
такая большая ошибка она ошибка
краткосрочно долгосрочной ошибка счет
продажи активов вот это точно не знаю
потому что это наверное но я не смог
предугадать потому что из-за санкций
действительно цены на машины вырастить
там в россии сейчас цена в научные
подержанные машины выросло поэтому ну
это я не мог предугадать и 1 одумался но
это краткосрочное явление сейчас очень
сильно наладился реэкспорт и поэтому
цены я думал тернов преподу но
однозначно первый вывод от сегодняшнего
подкастами во время кризиса не надо
делать резких движений это очень важно
вот первый пример когда до мир услышал
совет сразу побежал делать моментально
нас
этот a cup of metal случайно чтобы с
этим и понятнее вот сейчас за курс
укрепляет опал является как бы есть в
рубли рубли тенге а вы говорите что
обе это знаем вот там объяснили нам не в
краткосрочном периоде до деньги
укрепиться может долгосрочным но он
всегда будет девальвироваться потому что
никаких предпосылок нету для
долгосрочного укрепления деньги здесь
еще важно наверное отметить такой момент
что
вот
кризис это такое время когда в состоянии
полной неопределенности но представьте
себе такую ситуацию что с горы
собирается спускаться лавина вот я это к
тому что мне говорят вот вы
слишком категорично относитесь и
пугайте народ я говорю вот представь
такую ситуацию лавина собирается
спуститься появились первые камушки
сыпется но признаки и ты в это время
ведешь себя как
такой безбашенный оптимист это одни 3
поведения а второй deep когда ты
очень осторожный туз
в преддверии того что ты видишь признаки
надвигающейся лавины наверное все таки
лучше быть трусом чем
безбашенным оптимистом поэтому я когда я
говорю я подразумеваю что люди людям
людям вообще свойственно долго не
принимать кризиса я специально пугаю
чтобы быть быстрее реагировали в твоем
случае получил так что ты среагировал
очень быстро
этого ключа нас очень много это та
одноклубников козин клубе очень быстро
среагировать
перед вас после вашего
потому что смотрела то на меня тоже
сильно влияет честная последние два
несмотря на последних фото спорного
потом смотрю тут тоже это плохо это
плохой lada niva пока смотреть поэтому
во время весело но но я специально
говорю больше не то что специально пугай
я на самом деле говорю то что я сам
делаю я сам конвертирую я с первых дней
сразу все сто процентов
конвертировался максимально я вывожу в
кэш насколько возможно насколько нет там
крипто в ней крипто там ну вот схемами
то есть я всегда даю только те советы
или по-другому как американцы говорят
кушают отступ которую я вам предлагаю
было на тебе кас казался кризис власти
сказался кризис однозначного наверное
даже больше не на нас она наших клиентов
потому что мы продвигаем большой колеса
компании на территории всего из тенге те
компании которые были на стинга мы сами
пока на время перестали работать потому
что конвертация и вообще транзита плат
проходит очень долго и вот эксперты тоже
к вам продюсировали на территории снг
тоже пока взяли такую некую паузу у всех
было наверное в первую неделю страх того
что исчезну социальные сети то есть
инстаграм как бы однозначно сейчас вот
он заблокировали но хочу сказать сразу
что мы настолько сегодня привыкли к
социальным сетям мы настолько сегодня
привыкли вообще к инстаграму будет
просто адаптации людей с одной площадки
в другую что произошло волосы вообще
стиле грамм как telegram просто взорвал
очень быстро у нас это однозначно на нас
казалось сказалось формате того что
появился в момент страха какие-то курсы
которые мы преподавали то есть они стали
неактуальны и сегодня да потому что
площадке не работаю до вот здесь убрать
рынок россии площадка там из м м пока
немного там обучение курсом по smm да
наверное много пока против буду
откровенен потому что сейчас такая
ситуация пока непонятно но за по пути
наверное сейчас востребован и другие
профессии до того как можно сегодня на
хозяйством на бали сегодня зарабатывает
вас требует профессии как сегодня имея
наверное свою основную работу работы в
найме еще взять какой-то навык который
будет обеспечивать себе какую-то до вот
вот как то так то есть у нас это
наверное момент потери каких-то клиентов
пересмотрели тогда заработок даже есть
те клиенты которые скал астана у них
были поставки имена с россии и снг мы
пересмотрели бюджет потому что для них
уже это дорогого платье в этом наши
услуги и вот на те получается сказал
закрыть и соцсетей и то что тяжело
оплачивать значимость закрытие платежную
систему и вот именно у клиентов у нас
принципе как работали при другой новые
какие то возможны на стороне клиента
спрос просила же скажу часто для вас я
вообще молодой предприниматель и все
крис и я прохожу сейчас впервые то есть
если у вас есть опыт дата первый кризис
2 christ пандемии мы проходим дайте
все-таки окрестить его прикольно новая
задача то есть вот как раз таки то
поколение для которого наверно вот эти
все маленькие барьеры это как момент
решения задач то есть и не только я
большое колесо моих сверстников сегодня
к этим крисом относится более спокойно
формате а прикольно да придумать
обучится чему то новому сегодня же не
нужно обучаться в университете там что
значит зарабатывать какой то еще нам
какой то еще в итоге что-то но это с
другой стороны два знаешь это говорит о
том что на самом деле
по вам еще не бил кризис datacore
никогда не прикольно
этом пока вы испытывали только те кризис
который прикольно там раз пережили это
знаешь такое для маленький bump bump и
кое-какие как на волнах ты же не что о
подбросила неплохо поэтому я думаю если
будет серьезный кризис в этом плане
наверно моя другая у меня другая другой
опыт я пережил очень много кризисов и
очень глубоких и я для себя четко уловил
правило что если брать все периоды
кризисов которые я переживал всегда
плохо я переживал кризис когда я
реагировал медленно
проблема в том что у людей есть умер
ценность они медленно въезжают в кризис
двигаемся дальше санжары как мы на тебе
сказался кризис кризис нам не сказался в
моих двух ипостасях как актеры как
начинающий бизнесмен как актер из-за
войны очень много проектов отменились в
россии и
даже совместных проектов от этом сервисе
да у меня агенты российские одна из
крупнейших компаний в россии
представляет мои интересы но так уж
вышло что 4 крупнейших проекты которые
должны были снимать в россии просто
взяли заморозили на неопределенность
это первое второе как бизнесмен у меня
есть актерская школа война называется я
ее сам создал сам делал ремонт все права
выражаться есть момент когда люди после
берут счет ее ноября в сам с нуля создал
январских событий ударили хорошо то есть
мы набрали команду группу собирались
море запустится и произошло то что
произошло и нам с нуля пришлось опять
собирать людей люди были в панике
естественно и
ценовая политика уже их не устраивала
вот сейчас потихонечку выкарабкаемся и
плюсы и открыл отдельный бизнес он
вообще далек от творчеством около
творческий бизнес это вертикальный
принтер услуги вертикального при
достаточно интересная тема здесь на
открыли компанию здесь и в стамбуле и на
кого назвали томом а чем занимается на
деле нанесения на любую поверхность там
около 14 видит в поверхности любую
картину а почему называется вертикальный
print потому что у него принцип принтера
то есть взяли обычный принтер который
рисовал вот так горизонтально его
повернули так создали новую программу и
до трех метров дыры 3 спален с метров и
может нанести картину в длину бесконечно
как муралы
тональности
ли вы работать
не совсем да многие считают что мы
забрали работу но здесь больше
идет точность то есть если у художник
допустим вот ты можешь попросить
художника дорисовать так как он видит но
если клиенту нужно вот как на картинке и
то же самое нанести на стену мы даем и
время то есть там картина полтора на
полтора занимает час художника может
быть дочь но то что касается
студии которые приостановили съемки я
думаю сейчас будет взрыв именно новых
фильмов в россии потому что все западные
менеджеры прекратили поставки в россию и
они сейчас даже уже разрушили показ
фильмов блогеров уже дошло до того что
сожалению здесь есть обратная сторона
медали да возможно будет взрыв но бюджет
и будут урезаться сейчас но даже
менеджеры говорят менеджеры компании
говорят что те сериалы которые они
снимали из них будут делать полный метр
и то есть что рассчитывалась быть только
срочно сейчас будет укомплектовываться
так как это уже сейчас есть что было
начато до снимут а все что было
запланировано уже не будет ни
естественно очень много талантов уехала
из россии и сейчас перспектива такая что
будут брать молодых местных естественно
качество будет очень сильно страны но
всем понятно да вот кризис и имеет одно
свойство
ты точно не можешь предугадать
долгосрочные последствия то есть вот эти
видимые один на одну ступень на 2-ые
ступени мы можем предсказать а что
дальше будет конечно гораздо сложнее и
еще касательно того почему я всегда
настаиваю на том что надо и всегда
исходить из худшего сценария особенно во
время кризиса потому что любое общество
и любой человек воспринимает кризис или
любой беду проходит по 5 ст1 первая
стадия то 32 спать это гнев 3 торговля 4
депрессия пятое признание и принятие и
после принятия признания человек в
состоянии предпринимать какие-то
действия и что-то делать проблема в том
что общество тоже самое когда въезжает в
кризис первое время идет отрицание не
признают и я просто изучала у меня
хорошая книга была как-то
забыл уже давно что он называется по
моему почему
богатые теряют свои состояния что летняя
не бедные нет почему богатые почему
богатые теряют свои состояния вот там
было только про богата и как раз была в
том что они долго очень цепляются за те
прежние цены когда на бирже цена на
акции падает вот у него была своя цена
акции было 100 долларов и цена начала
падать 90 думать блин вот до 100 дойдет
и я продам а цена падает до 70 он думает
ну чего я на девяносто не продал вот до
90 дойдет blind продам она падает до 50
думает плена fda на 70 продавать тот я
дурак ладно сейчас хоть чуть-чуть она
подпрыгнет до 60 продав цена падает до
40 35 он думает ну все теперь смысла нет
продавать не буду сидеть до конца и как
правило конец заканчивать м что партия
падает до нуля то же самое вы можете
посмотреть паттерн саддама хусейна когда
была война в квейке он захватил кувейт
ему горит братан ты не прав отойди
нет ему бы это отойди мы сейчас тебя
наместо поставим говорит нет американцы
подогнали авианосцы он говорит нет
американцы отвоевали cuvee уговорит нет
его до конца добили в то время как ему
можно когда уже авианосцы подошли
сказать войск о рыцаре я погорячился
отошел опять кубик вернулся но я напал
потому что мне нужен был выход к морю
или вот
портовая инфраструктура
дайте мне к вот и как-то можно отсюда
что-то выторговать он лишь не
зафиксировал в ухе а он стоял до конца
до конца до конца и конец ничего
хорошего не привел поэтому я из своего
опыта знаю что общество идет по вот
этому вот этим стадиям и
из-за вот этого неприятия потом
происходит проблемы и есть и ты тоже
стоящую муж нет нет и все будет хорошо
все будет хорошо
обычно всегда все закончится плохо по
крайней мере смотрите
за все кризисе которые переживала я
пережил очень много кризисов быть
параноиком по поводу крис рисков и
опасностей никогда не доводила до
банкротства или до гибели
это эта стратегия которая точно
обеспечивает выживаемость то есть и
личная паранойя или излишней страх и в
этом плане да мир ты в этом плане
краткосрочно ты проиграл например да и
ребята тоже которым меня послушали но
долгосрочно ты точно не то что даже
выиграл ну точно игры остался в игре
тоже надо же зависит от цели ты хочешь
сейчас заработать на кризисе или
остаться живым ну не обанкротится
поэтому такая стратегия важнее тебе же
то что касается вот мы
в первом приближении обсудили поговорили
по поводу у кого как кризис
а спутает что вы думаете что будет
дальше
может без очереди что что будет дальше
куда вот ваши предположения можете по
своей о трасте говорит там вам форчун
что думаешь и как вообще и как ты
думаешь как долго кризис продлится как
глубоко он будет
честно я уже я от 15 открыл ресторан
взяв людей там в долю в долларах и помню
там 19 августа 15 м году у нас antivir
ваться я только что получил transparent
получил транш выбрал
доллар в тенге это 7 договорись долларов
зафиксировали курс да и они мне дали в
тенге но в долларах то я поехал банк
конвертировать и в тот же день у меня
было деваться то есть как бы и получатся
я продал долю не за условно говоря
550 тыс долларов а там там был спрос
доллара в
горах об шутеры и вот вот этот ужасный
момент до сих пор помню там пятом низко
ли вы пилотом на нам месяц-другой и там
себестоимость очень у нас подорожала в
ресторанном бизнесе тот момент и после
этого я понял что принял для себя
решение что я не буду теперь играть и
там всегда я попытался подсознательно
тоже хочу отыграться я попытался там
славе что-то понять я понял что я всю
энергию все внимание трачу на курс
нежели на свой бизнес со своим бизнеса я
больше заработал год и с того момента я
принял решение никогда не играть в игры
форекс это условно говоря то
необходимо
сохранять все поймете да так чтобы там
гоняться в угол и тем больше продать
удачно купить вот эту идею у меня них и
там не было и это я считаю что да я там
очень много терял если смотреть задним
числом но в момент я ж не знал
это были моменты когда я вот я очень но
больше сэкономил когда я не лист в эту
игру
поэтому и потом и потому что
предугадывать очень сложно почему потому
что вообще непонятно то есть как бы тоже
здесь по методике posted on the
political непонятно вот так получилось
что
долг в ноябре что я прошел курс по
стратегическим midget по маркетингу
получил захотел тут раз юта учусь и там
ни говорили от есть внешние факторы
политика экономика социально-культурной
из технологий горную начаться чем не
нужна какая-то за там объясняет
качестве предлога и я понимаю 6
действительно дома около 100 и политика
влияет очень сильно экономит очень
сильно вляет ну блин кто тут у нас
инверсия быть и российских зрителей не
особо не меня зовут чувствует не вот в
своем через свой ракурс воспринимать
этот крыса у нас это же пол часа два
удара уже через месяц мы январе очень
сильно получили к пушке и в феврале у
нас получить по башке и в этом очень
упорный удар и
знаю я перестал вообще позитивно что-то
делать потому что хотя наш мозг он хочет
чтобы мы предполагали и вот ежедневно
еженедельными цветами двигаюсь смотрим
потому что меняется отчеству на примерку
сейчас 450 70 до тогда прошлом прошлой
неделе у нас было 500 чем-то и там мы
принимать решение часов я вот сейчас
принятие решение опустил до уровня и
деле у нас учатся бартон там собираемся
в субботу 10 часов принимаем там
фиксируем что как что работа это не
работает потому что как бы все меняется
и в савин план на неделю и в plant
обработаем что работает до сих пор
продолжаются не работать видео принципе
перестала считать чудо планировать
потому что вообще сам станет ну а вы
какую как куда пойдет все это как как на
ужин я скажу я думаю что
это хорошо отразится на рынке почему
потому что действительно я не люблю
слова то не falcon я не люблю это слово
но как бы ну вот именно шуменов и за тех
людей которые вас особо только совершу
если они пришли этот зато легкой добычей
но точно так не получиться и
соответственно не думаю что ну наверно
теперь у вас там за те люди которым
любить это дело потому что я вот когда
мы основали свою школу там с понятием
архимаг первые четыре месяца не получали
прибыль и вообще мы были в убытках я
софи себе в карман только на девятый
месяц получил деньги небольшие деньги на
9 месте я понимаю что вы же говорили
помню . год надо сравнивая соревноваться
не
но не другие маус то есть у любой у
которой учились когда бизнесу поэтому
ужас эти люди которые будут
ну только любить свое дело потому что
все таки преподавания образования то не
так же тоже не кирпичный завод там же
чувствует поэтому
кажется все закончится уже уже закончили
чувствую потому что уже банки перегретой
на наличкой банки и они как бы
зарабатывал у тебя внутри являться идет
в любом случае нужно а ну видимо рынок
пиривет приношу переселиться ван и у них
не наличных очень много потому что бы
сбербанк других пока вам перейти и не
знаю наверно единственного я насчет как
бы наверно вас кредитные риски то я
увеличить и опять выдавать подавать тут
будут нормально все будет но для меня
этот момент что-то знаете был тест по
церна любовь к своему делу потому что
уже по силе тоже жирком опроса это же
начал думать так наверное чем то другим
вот заниматься но вот этот шоколад по
лицу именно это же потому что ж уже тоже
вот на ручное управление
переходишь и и уже понимаю что там очень
много уроков поставлять вам преподаю
поэтому думаю это такое очень хорош
естественно насколько я люблю свое дело
это но тех людей которые не любят они
уйдут к только западе ним пришли ты
думаешь это положительно скажется на
рынке на рынках положиться потому что и
думала и они они не могут даже потому
что знаете иначе будет так собчак
снимать ролики бестолковую в итоге
сейчас она будет принимать как бы
выдавать делает свое курсе тут вопрос не
понятно из-за чистого сердца до делается
или это была такая методика рекламщики
ты не понимаешь те люди которые даже с
вами hyip уютно этой теме и только
запускать свой курс вот этот кризис
идеально все почистил без хайпа без
ничего останутся те люди которые
эксперты а те люди которых звука
халтурит новых не будучи в берлин это
будет хорошо но вот небольшой коммент к
словам
фарша
ты правильно подметил что не надо играть
на вот этих курсах дело в том что у меня
был такой случай когда
девальвация в каком году была когда со
180 на 320
ну ладно я помнил хорошо это день это
было 19 августа 115 19 августа и я
начиная с июня сидят всем своим
компаниям куда я инвестировал говорил
переходите сто процентов наводят на
доллары на доллары конвертируйте на
доллары я чувствую будет кризис
конвертируйте этот будет девальвация
отвели хоббиты говорил полтора два
месяца
происходит 19 девальвация и от такой
есть и от четко все просчитал все угадал
и так далее так далее и тут выясняется в
одной из моей крупной компании по одной
крупной компании они
не конвертировали в доллары потому что
они окажутся большую сумму ней положили
в тенге на депозит и
там так если ты знаешь депозит раньше
срока то деньги процент и не платится
депозит заканчивался 20 августа
поставлять и вот и они думали ну да я
говорил конвертирует кавер вертя но они
же я им дату не стал что так вот dota
такого что потому что я ж не знал когда
точно будет дата но я знал что будет
точно девальвации вот они держать
держали и 19
августа ударил девальвация 20 не
заканчивался депозит так вот я вам
просто скажу что мы потеряли три
миллиона 200 тысяч долларов
просто на девальвации и
при этом в процентах если посчитать то
что там они пытались сэкономить ну
наверно 1150
заработали
150.000 доллар потеряли приземленность я
на ком поставили больше прибыль от 200
это потери и так вот я это говорю о том
что это когда тот случай когда надо
резко двигаться резко не надо пытаться
выиграть на вот и их скачках курса до
попал где-то выиграл где-то это но ты не
знаешь что дальше мы основная проблема
не знаем что будет завтра поэтому завтра
раз условного будет курс 600
акасия красавчик вчера говорил не
.
поэтому я считаю так нужно здесь и тогда
ну понятно я сразу собрал этот я таким
случаем обязательно потом принимаем
стандарт почему это произошло
анализируем его просто вот кого то
ругать увольнять не создашь люди делали
просто они делали это недопонимая и
я четко им объяснил смотреть игры вы
играли в две игры на игра это валютного
трейдера спекулянты одна игра
производственник если это производстве
тебе сказали конвертирую конвертирует по
любому курсу все какая первая потом
почему ты собирался зарабатывать на
процентах зачем ты это ну чтоб слой
основной же за за rabanne произведите
произвести дешево продать дороже и на
этом зарабатывать они на процента то
есть при залез валютные операции то есть
в спекулятивные операции и вот результат
вот такой поэтому очень важно разделять
свой основной бизнес доход от основа
бизнеса и доход от валютных и лактации
не играйте на валютных рынках на
валютных флуктуациях
первое правило обеспечьте себе
выживаемость а это обеспечивает и есть
вы действуете быстрее чем толпа
это вот этот как раз то ремарка тит
теперь второй комментарии то что
касается рынка образования дело в том
что рынок образования сам по природе
своей антикризисный он антикризисного
время кризиса растет рынок образования и
во время кризиса растет игры уже
доказано что чем выше уровень
безработицы в сша тем больше люди играют
в игры хлеб сжечь и второй момент чем
больше кризис тем больше людей ищут
способа поменять свою профессию и
освоить новую профессию и так далее
поэтому рынок дополнительного взрослого
образования растет поэтому в этом плане
я думаю этот мир никуда не уйдёт ты прав
что это очиститься от тех кто не так
любит свой бизнес но рынок
дополнительного взрослого образования и
образования взрослых я думаю он мудрость
нами ты думаешь как будет развиваться в
твоей сфере в твоём бизнес
но вообще как бы я анализировал вот эти
ситуации вот как я поддерживал хуан ешь
а вот эти два события которые были у нас
январский и вот сейчас и врали случились
я понял что очень сложно оказывается
прогнозировать что-то потому что то что
мы предполагали что это но невозможно
казалось бы невозможные вещи нереальные
из области фантастики
оказывается это абсолютно реальные вещи
более того это становится нормой это
становится нормой да я понял такую вещь
вот то что ваш принцип вы говорите
берите самых худших да это-то
сценарий то есть имейте виду что может
случиться самый худший сценарий потому
что и в первом событий во втором событии
это были вещи которые вообще не входили
я думаю никому в голову даже и
после этого сейчас то что мы видим то
что происходит я вот тоже самое сделал
как хуа наш получается мы планируем
сейчас ну буквально там два-три дня я
больше не планирую потому что но
неизвестно что будет завтра там какие
новые условия принесу принесет но это
реальность да поэтому мы максимально вот
сократили время то что мы раньше
планировали году год там месяц это далее
мы это сократили там надо труднее не до
недели это до трех дней максим более
того я сам планирую на один день только
только что будет завтра все вот вот
такие вещи проделали а что касается
нашего бизнеса
я думаю скорее всего вот правильно
планер сказал тоже опять же будут
уходить слабые игроки потому что она все
равно получается цена
покупательская способность она все равно
станет опуститься ниже и нужно каким-то
другими методами привлекать покупателей
то есть уже не будут конкурентоспособны
другие компании и останутся только те
кто делают дополнительно что то какие то
новые выходы новые шаги и там оптимизм и
оптимизацию ну и так далее то есть я
думаю вот так вот уже добавлю сюда
х быть очка у нас когда я поговорить с
ранкорами он как будучи мог заняться но
открыто же ресторан и он спасибо вам
посоветовал тебе говорю смотри
что я сделал правильно уровне этой я
села за правильно правильно сегменты
потому что
когда нашу соду скажем сегмент это
как
с.б. вот примерно такая такая история
почему потому что
мне в целом
чек маленький но каждый блюд одну
определены то есть как бы вот такая
история
большой процент американцев бы ты
молчала кошек одно блюдо кушает но то
блюдо с толпой по себе дорогое
он платит меньше из-за того что он уже
наелся
вот эта история и что произошло когда
вот девальвация пошла мы получили очень
много отклики и клиентов сверху то есть
который выше нас у нас ведь через и был
10 тысяч тенге и к нам вовсе не сразу
люди которые там
5005 dota которых они не особо как
почувствовали здесь у нас как было когда
он говорил как-то может отказ панды
метров вон бин вот мол то он будет
закрываться ты тоже займись сегмент
примерно плюс минус 8 8 5 долларов от
810 долларов весь свой бизнес накормить
людей сытно на этом на этом чите почему
потому что любая история те люди которых
сверху аня как будто они спустятся
потому что они уже привыкли кушать
вне дома нужно куда-то где-то
встречаться а уже там уже дорого потому
что его обычная уже все вести весь чем
этот на пятнадцатом году которую руку
физик который свыше 5000 тенге это
обычно очень много там импорта я не
автоматически должен быть поднимать
крикете вот здесь непонятно поднимается
и
падает и тут ты ловишь их спокойно я
сейчас мы замечаем что-то фанатам нужно
вот как бы но вот он очередной рекорд
докажем кресси закрывает поэтому считаю
здесь очень важно понять максимально там
какая-то моя ниша и 7 сегменты и только
обслуживать йода не питаться потому что
я же когда у меня был косяк польши когда
я попытался спрыгнуть на выше сегментов
сдала вот это был мой моей самой большой
ошибкой
фонишь говорит его совет что очень четко
нужно определить свой сегмент и
обслуживают именно его не пытаться
прыгать из сегментов сегменты и ловить
всех клиентов
районе сильно которая будет любом случае
денежным не ну понятно это должен быть
там должно быть прибыль иначе смысла нет
не обслуживать не прибыльный сегмент а
вот здесь еще дополню тоже очень многие
сегодня выпускают работу
клиентоориентированность то есть
особенность что происходит сегодня с
рынком можно заказать там рекламу у
блоггеров запустить рекламу этой всегда
найти нового клиента вот как все
началось у нас началось вот мы вирус
начали работать первое что мы сказали
клиентам работайте над своими действиями
7 клиентами которые у вас когда-то
купили почему потому что если смотреть
на воронку продаж она как в дуршлаг
клиенту пола мы продали все из-за были а
сейчас такое время когда начинается дым
fixed большая конкуренция и всем своим
клиентам начали горит то что ребят нам
нужно сплотиться и сперва сохранить тех
клиентов которые делали с вами какое-то
касание это могут быть это мероприятие
то может быть это даже не знаю простым
ништяки который можно по социальным
сетям отправить просто сделать так чтоб
сегодня клиенты заметили вас особенно
это хорошо как будто произошло в россии
от особенно в ритейле до instagram когда
закрылся если мы думаем что все таки
осознанные люди сразу скачали weekend в
ошибаемся многие вообще не знаешь такое
vpn там и как зайти в инстаграм и лучшие
что помогло это просто обычная рассылка
наполнили клиентам что вы у нас покупали
дали какую-то скидку и вот как раз здесь
тоже год поддерживаем вас то что очень
важно сейчас работа на клиент
ориентированность я бы сказал для тех
кто в интернет-маркетинге наверно больше
фокусируется не на конверсию она рейтинг
на удержание тех которые уже email
адреса которых у вас уже есть базе да я
скажу что благодаря этой стратегии мы
а вот
вторая половина февраля и первая
половина марта самое ужасное место самое
ужасное время как бы для дела не бизнеса
оставляя стартовал курса нового продукта
14 и мы на
вкус менять а 200 тыс двор мы продали к
продали продукты на именно в это время
такие были а потом у нас уже что-то
покупали потому что помню что смысла
нету а из-за того что люди не дают
рассрочку они идут на
дату дайте потому что
привык ушу как это знаете то же самое
продавать mercedes по ниже себестоимости
меняешь
бессмысленно операции летать и вверх
чтобы вас привода мне кажется чтобы
наверно правильно porsche мысль
объяснить смотрите есть два способа один
способ вот есть ваши клиенты которые
беднеют и уходят в нижний сегмент не
надо гнаться за гнаться вместе с ними и
у опуская цену на свою продукцию ходить
в нижний сегмент надо продолжать
обслуживать свой сегмент потому что ваши
клиенты опуститься уйдет ниже а верхний
клиента пусть они придут к вам у нас
раньше система именно в кино которую мы
потеряли давным-давно потому что есть
зритель которому сейчас пытается
достучаться наши киношники а зритель то
к сожалению
грубо говоря раньше как было выходит
кино и люди пытаются подражать этому
всему они перенимают прически манеру
разговора между и так далее то есть кино
обучала эта часть идеологии борода а
сейчас вышло так что мы опустились до
уровня зрителей пытаемся показать то что
они уже знают и уже нет никакого
обучения табора деградации и с каждым
разом всё хуже и хуже потому что раньше
кино был лидером общественно мнения а
сейчас и но пытаются угадать
общественные и следовать за обществ
мнением то есть развернулась ситуация на
и новый развлекательный контент
приостановили ли в россии
в россии где им как я не скажу за всю
одессу да как в песне конкретно могу
сказать что там что-то снимается но не в
тех масштабах как раньше до дна и
опять-таки как вы сказали то что фильм
блогеров но это это уже не тема понятна
естественно я к тому что часто это это
же не от хорошей жизни во первых
смотрите в большие кинотеатры и
построенный мультиплекс и так далее им
надо что-то показывает спроса и он как
бы жался но не до такой степени чтобы
остаться без зрелищ а зрелищ нет у
соответственно я думал вот мое мнение ну
ты свое скажи sender подскажи что
конечно однозначно вырастет
предложение форме патриотическую в кино
я с я смотрю сейчас бьет рекорды выручки
фильмы брат один брат 2 но хотя это 100
старое кино уже давно одно это
соответствует моменту вот именно
появится твой психологии российского
зрителя человеками остался зрительного
год зритель там не осталось вот этот
фильм брат он ярко показывает вот этот
пренебрежение к американцам что вот у
них что вот у россиян есть такое свое
только вот это ну ну не буду его плохо
ничего говорить но вот яркие иллюстрации
психо вы которые сейчас есть и вот я
думаю сейчас вот такие фильмы +
военно-патриотический потому что россии
надо качать патриотизм сейчас будут
переписывать историю на себя и это
начнут симов сначала фильмах начнёт
искажать факты
потом дальше и дальше как это было во
всех закрытых странах на данный момент
они будут писать так что якобы мы самые
лучшие надо а с другой стороны хорошо
это часть развития кеном нам понятно
будет военно-патриотическое кино с
бюджетом финансироваться там они
красавчики весь состоянии умерла хи
давай мы это обсуждать не будем это
потому что они не столько развлекаловка
сколько идеология а давай мы поговорим о
кино развлекаловки
потому что ну есть кино понятно
идеологическое которое формирует
общественную повестку дня там педали
есть кино трендовая которое покажется
вообще тренды для общества формируют
тренды какие прическа одежда
культ и культуры поведения и так далее а
есть кино развлекательное вот
развлекательный к новым которому к
сожалению все кино скатилась
развлекательное кино вот ты как бы мышь
я просто на друг на казахстанских
режиссеров и казахстанские фильмы а мне
нравится я мне нравится казахский ума
рынок начал ходить на все эти фильмы
нурлан клан bad протасов домбайский
фильм ну сейчас много же ночные боли
баян выпускает мне нравится в принципе
легкий юмор который прошел посмотрел
забыл
понятно там нету такого что там селению
компания просто пришел с детьми поржал
паев по форме ушел и
вот как ты думаешь вообще и в россии в
казахстане вашей перспективы кинул какие
об этом я читал очень много сейчас
статей что в россии будет скорее всего
сниматься большую часть только комедий в
том что это самое один из самых дешевых
жанров раз во вторых по статистике чем
хуже ситуация в стране в государство тем
больше снимается комедий до людей и
стендов будет развиваться еще сильной
агрессивность сожаления туризм из города
стендап цензура цензура не могут жить
вместе до сожалению стандарт наоборот
будет гасить это уже и гасят у меня же
много знакомых в россии на стандарты raw
и юморист цензура просто их убивает до
январских событий можно тоже посмотреть
эту статистику
очень много комедий снимались супер
дешевых там где бюджет 5000 долларов до
10 лишь там или какова была на там еще
побольше намного больше но любом случае
комедии сейчас является самым
рентабельным во первых люди хотят как-то
немножко абстрагироваться от цены нижней
жизни посмотреть посмеяться с другой
стороны и продюсеры хотят заработать
потому что фильм в казахстане при
идеальных условиях когда это было
допустим год назад он не должен
превышать 100 тыс долларов да да ты хотя
бы забрал свое и может быть что-то дачу
на данном этапе мне кажется он еще
дешевле будет чувствовать то есть мы
скатываемся больше к узбекской такой
манере съемок в плане что дешево но
быстро можно снимать на фотоаппарат
107 в год и главное чтобы они показали в
конце 3 поснимали следующую этот
конвейер положили 10 тысяч получили 16
что снимаем 16 получили 32 снимаем опять
что задавал жол g-7h много тратится на
на производство кино ну на тот когда он
запускал тогда это были идеальные
условия
кинотеатры россия в норме то есть он же
и на экспорт это тоже показывал там не
турцию была замешана может быть в россии
могли купить эту франшизу но сейчас
опять таки из за того что происходит
перед непонятно что будет дальше то есть
я представляю мой прогноз на то что у
нас будет очень много приедут экспертов
с россией с украины к нам они будут
пытаться найти себя здесь переходим к
тексту покрупнее будет пытаться собрать
вокруг себя какую-то команду и уже
опять-таки мы будем на них работать к
сожалению если мне что-то не поменяю до
этого них не хочется у себя в стране
работать на кого-то сейчас данный момент
вообще так ситуация приходит до люди вот
потихонечку я получаю письма уже от моих
ребят знакомых они как между нами
становится игрой слушай вот такой
человек полетел очень круто специалист
посмотри вот такой человек прилетел
очень хороший специалист вот такой кейс
пристроить его я чувствую что это я не
только один причем ладно я начинающий
продюсер мне кажется другим такие письма
приходят каждый день а вот вопрос condes
вы же больше так для больше 13
интернационале без сделайте это с у вас
команды
классический а как просили для
казахскоязычной аудитории
есть некая такая внутренняя тревога что
придут
экспаты
специалисты не принимать или ну понятно
более-менее to clean a тоже сюда работал
отдавать из-под специалисты которые
отберут у них работу да это вопрос
компетенции данного как бы давно
уверенности комплекс может быть она есть
только факт ну как вы относитесь к тому
что люди придут хорошие специалисты да и
аким людей слепо людей вчера у нас
посадить еще тысячи людей пришли за
schloss россии официально неофициально
будешь смотрите я вообще так считаю что
в этом ничего страшного нет вы вспомните
как китай китай вообще выполнял функцию
просто наемных работников по сути рабов
у себя на территории
благодаря тому что
рабочая сила была дешевая всем крупным
корпорациям было выгодно размещать
производство в китае но вот здесь
переломный момент
китайцы смогли понять что не теперь
нужно им учиться и они начали учиться
копировать к учиться копировать учиться
копировать сейчас в китайских заводах
работают только китайцы на всех
руководящих позициях проблема в том что
не проблема в наплыве на специалистов
это супер благо без специалистов будут
просто проблемы вот у меня
там в доме о система умный дом но я так
скажу ни одного казаха нет ни одного
казаха который разбирается причем я
прошерстил весь в у нас в алматы астана
только
нашел специалистов двигались только в
москве то есть умным домом по сути вот
если вы возьмёте фирмы которые
занимаются из системы умный дом в в
казахстане там казахов 12
возьмите
электриков энергетиков инженеров в
intellitone кавказе везде русские
украинцы везде кто-то ну проблема не в
них проблема в казахов казаки должны
начать изучать
ну хорошо давайте мы всех экспатов
специалисты выгоним и стороны что это не
знать что появится наши инженера обители
точки это значит что мы будем до
инфляцию делать через форточку открывать
окна мы просто останемся без вентиляции
и безумного дома вот что будет вас не
будут умного дома и выделяться вот если
естественная конкуренция до появляется
да я наоборот считаю что сейчас такая
ситуация когда приезжает много экспатов
с россией и многое экспатов с украиной и
конкуренции на рынке труда только
конкуренция может заставить человека
поднять задницу и начать что-то изучать
сделать все другого варианта нет
искусственный барьер я не верю
законодательные запреты кого ты и так
далее я это не веру это ни к чему не
приведет это приведет только к полной
деградации
поэтому вот сейчас есть и киношники
приезжают с россией да к сожалению нашим
придется работать на них к сожалению но
это недолго через какое-то время уровень
наших вырастет и наши будут на высоте
потому что я смотрю это во всех сферах
[музыка]
самое главное я в не верю в
искусственные запретительные меры и
преграды теперь вниз касательно кризиса
смотрите очень важный момент я хотел бы
отметить
дело в том что в восприятии людей
большинство людей воспринимает кризис
как одноразовая события вообще мы люди
не приспособленные мысли динамики мы
мыслим как любые вещи хотим объяснить и
воспринимаем как 1 раза событие вот
когда кризис случился вот кризис говорят
пришел да многие люди кризис
воспринимают как пулю которая пролетела
вас него такое coupe фух пронесло
бли-и-ин думай так все говорят кризис
все вокруг херово а меня не зацепила или
зацепила помянем так теперь куда бы мне
инвестировать но сразу начинает искать
возможности куда инвестируйте и так
далее то есть такой одноразово быть
крысята кому то вы на самом деле кризис
это не в это кризис вот отсюда и
медленно твоей жены будет тянуть
вытягивать твои соки
на протяжении долгого если сейчас тебя
не зацепило зацепит следующем месяце не
в следующем зацепит следующем месяце
никто никуда с корабля не убежит никто
поэтому вот здесь вопрос такой что для
того чтобы понимать природу крис и нужно
понимать внутренней динамику все кризисы
разные но у всех кризисов есть
одинаковая внутренняя структура она
состоит из инфраструктуры первое
зарождение кризиса второе развитие
кризис и третье ускорение четвертое
замедление 5 одно так вот если ты на
начальной стадии мы сейчас находимся в
стадии развития крис не начало развития
но впереди ждет ускорение так вот если
ты на этой стадии начнешь заниматься
инвестированием ты гарантированно
попадешь
потому что все равно все будет падать
цене все будет падать почему я говорил
долгосрочной перспективы все будут
падать и
так что когда вот лови на sb с горы идет
ты в город беде не бегите лавина все
равно вниз унесет или когда течение
против тебя идет так вот как гребите of
сигналов унесет то есть обеднеют все во
время кризис поэтому нужно четко
понимать стадии мы стадию зарождения
кризиса прошли а чем характеризуется
когда формируется внутренние условия для
кризиса но один людям еще не видно света
резные потому что потом появляется
стадия
развития кризиса когда уже внешние
проявления есть все знают все об этом
говорят но и еще люди не прочувствовали
вот ударов мы сейчас в этой стадии
находится мы сейчас говорим но по факту
лично нас еще сильно не ударял где-то до
цена выросла где-то рынок присел где-то
этнос сильно прямо сейчас еще не удалил
вот на стадии ускорение это будет стадия
когда все уже знают что из кредит все
видят его кризис и вылезти лично
прочувствовали и
сосна станет замедления то когда все
знают что кризисы в видят кризис
прочувствовали но уже свыклись с это вам
с этим и приняли это как норма и дно это
когда люди уже настолько к этому
привыкли
перестают поступать плохие новости и
люди начинают потихоньку мечтать что они
будут делать после кризис и вот на
стадии дна надо инвестировать
но но до этого надо кыш вот этот донести
до стадии дна потому что он каждым будет
утекать надо его донести вот это
проблема и
поэтому когда мы говорим о том что куда
будет развиваться кризис предугадать
сложно потому что свойство кризис это
высокая степень неопределенности мой
собирает природу кризис и почему
возникает всегда кризисе будете взять
выбрать любой психологические семейные
экономические военные кризисе и так
далее это всегда
несоответствие
а несоответствия образ жизни в
реальности который есть вот и
соответствие твоего поведение твой
реальность вот когда условно два
человека подрались почему потому что
одним прошел даром годы как дела тот год
или ты чего херсон почему на толкаешь то
есть я пришел с ожиданием что я толкнул
он прогнется
моего представления не соответствовало
реальности по то же происходит с россией
украины россии на одном сейчас за три
дня я киев возьму раз все развернулась
ожидания не соответствовать реальности и
вот всегда когда происходит
несоответствие ожиданий и реальности
либо образа жизни и когда ты на кредит
покупаешь камеры и правой что и образа
жизни и реальности всегда происходит
кризис кризис он всегда вы как бы
человека на землю опускает это братан ты
уже в облаках давай назад поэтому
начинают работать и ночная да и это как
раз поэтому
нужно понимать вот эти фазы кризиса
криса ним тоже не случайно они привязаны
к психологии людей как раз таки
психология отрицание гнев торговля
депрессия и принять и вот чем быстрее ты
примешь что крис пришел тем быстрее ты
согласишься что приду да еще не
наступили плохие последствия но для себя
ты принял что наступит обязательно
перестрахуемся тем больше шансов что ты
доживешь до конца кризис и
вот это то что касается
кризис а вот теперь в целом что вы лично
сами предпринимаете в бизнес и в личной
жизни поделитесь какими-то секретами
лайфхаками что как действовать в кризис
как я считаю что
кредитов мы от вас учились что это вот
неопределенность и
неопределенности значит получается
ориентир на будущее держать смысла нету
соответственно раз у нас смысла как
будем как человек есть сейчас есть
прошлое и будущее кризис это про будущее
у нас про рыбу смутно мы понимаем про
будущее прошлое ну как бы она там
понятное дело значит мы туда не можем
прорваться и как бы через какие-то
страдания через какие-то тревоги и мы
хоть хоть что-то хотим оттуда рвать из
будущего было теперь знаете что делать
надо значит успокоиться и перестать про
будущее вообще думать то есть почему
потому что энергии ты сэкономишь и
возвращаешься в настоящее и в настоящем
значит и может управлять только двумя
вещами а сны ничего не можем управлять
потому что ты не можешь управлять
поведением клиентов там в банками да ты
можно управлять туловище 1 вещь это твое
состояние они твои действия состояние в
каком состоянии находится потому что
состояние твои потом определяет твое
поведение если ты там в опатии что
кстати происходит да тут у меня там в
чудо вавринка с я сплю потому что я не
пью это вот моя психо хочет избежать вот
этого негатива только только с они
вместе он пытается уснуть или там и
серий сериала см это же то если вот твое
состояние его состояние это вот вопрос
через медитации через определенные там
практики или там через религиозных это
практики или ходьба спорт
фродо почему потому что первостепенное
состояние состояние определяет
действие теперь вот ты сам вот что из
этого делаешь не thatwill медитирую
медитирую там ходьба учить машину в
религиозной практике
умеет очень сильно и потом у меня есть
методика дали кодировать и научиться
управлять внутренним состоянием дом
состоянии это по сути или это обида
страх чувство вины там например почему
ты не можешь остановить условно говоря
жду меня щас открою своим родителям дом
я понимаю что я вот теми темпами который
я обещал им не могу то строить или могу
в ущерб
финансовым падуб фраза подушки теперь
должен сесть поговорить родителям мама
папа смотрите и строится на я обещаю мы
идем ко всему этого этой истории но не
будет я обещала рамазан не получится
поздароваться когда будет но дай бог у
дасти теперь мы закончим ну вот ну
почему мы не можем именно тот диалог
вестей почему потому что мы чувствуем
чувство вины у нас 6 инвестора вот
определенно пять чувств которые у нас
определяет все и тревогу почему мы
боимся актами что-то встретили какие-то
страхи вают дамы с долгами не запросы
сюрприз за долги потом нибудь их такого
что такое на и и соответственно очень
принципиально очень важно именно
научиться контролировать состояние
почему потому что
состояние от состояния у нас есть
действия всегда если у нас нету 10
значит у нас в составе например человек
влюбленным он любом случае это будет
делать то есть именно чувства эмоции
определяет 10 и
мной но не будь это провести вот
качество весь моменте неправильно потому
что сказать реально то есть мы не
говорим про качество действия мы говорим
про вообще в целом действие и получат
очень почему архиважно научиться
контролировать свое состояние потому что
ты контролировать свои состояния можно
контролировать свои действия то есть
получается вот что я сделал я вот решил
остановиться потому что у меня
действительно были панические атаки вот
потому что я понимаю что там у нас есть
обязательства я должен мама папа скажет
ведь сказал я же в stories выложил что я
дострою до изгибе из обязательства
морально обязательно хотя меня никто не
выгоняет этот кайф кайф во в желто
ничего плохого ничего нету но
именно вот внутренние ощущения когда ты
не можешь управлять этим состоянием
получается ты как знаю как большая сосна
которую ветер дует стал сос с левой
стороны с правой стороны
вопрос время жду пойдешь поэтому именно
вот эта гибкость внутренние душевные
психически я почему потому что я
инструмент инструментарии как все другие
инструментарии они меняют вот например
то . уменьшение ждет опустить цену
припомни наказ не работает на что такое
поэтому единственное вот раз кризис это
внешне отражение что-то кризис душевно
тоже внешние вот это факторы начинает
влиять на тебе на примере если на улице
холодно ну ты хорошо одет как опасно
было нереально я сама холодная . где был
но из-за того чтобы красной где-то были
обувь и классно было внешние факта не
особо не повлияли здесь тоже сама внешне
у нас неопределенность есть но мне
кажется что нужно научиться в псехако
удержать адеквате потому что если ты не
научишься было случайно получится стресс
а если hi5 сгс 3 регистрация когда ты
вовремя средства регрессируют не
пронесет регистрируешь а почему люди
именно во время каких-то вот странных
новостей идут покупать туалета бумагу
принести это в корзине рептильный мозг
мы инстинктивно
уже начинаем запасаться
гречневую кашу гречку ехать на
правильное питание поэтому я все начали
кушать всегда у нас заражаясь гречка
почему-то
как будто мы планируем кушать гречку
поэтому вот
так
ты используешь бумагу
[смех]
[музыка]
. моя очень многое я тоже люблю причине
был и потому что идите а вот просто
из-за событий вы же не покупаете но
после инварс события сделать
корректировку я что держу под родов
мечты запасов продуктов потому что в
январе через пять дней у меня дома
закончишь продукт и
в реальные потому хорошо я там у меня
есть люди как привести достать магазин
там один магазин недалеко от нас богом
закрытый он для нас его открыл нам
продал продукты и так далее ну хорошо а
если вы нет я понял что на в январских
событиях я понял что очень быстро можно
спуститься на средневековый уровень
очень мы сейчас
видами объясняя все я по
черная почему есть своих советах ютюбе
тоже говорю закупить и вот чем держать
национальную валюту не обязательно
бежать сразу на доллары ну просто
увеличите запас продуктов питания 1 а за
увеличить запас
медикаментов которые вы берете потом
особенно если они импортные то есть не
так что мои советы не воспринимать так
что берегите пока все покупать только
доллары купить и медикаменты купить
продукты питания купить эти продукты
питания увеличить и еще можешь запас
которые не портятся там делайте 4 5
месячный запас продуктов по любому жижи
вы будете их покупать так лучше деньги
или национальной валюты превратить в
продукты питания то есть вариант такой
либо продукты питание либо в валюту там
и так далее поэтому я лично запасы
продуктов питания вылечил меня конечно
некоторые обвиняют что я типа зачем
такие советы даю из за того что я такие
советы даю люди бегут магазин из-за
этого не хватает продуктов питания
вопрос сердца как кому-то другому не
хватает и так далее гуру подождите 10
смотрите
это государство чиновники они обязаны
так говорить но я-то точно знаю что в
жизни для жизни каждого личного человека
мои советы работает это первыми второй
момент во время кризиса вообще работает
правило не верь не бойся не проси
нам закон зеленый закон потому что
кризис он как власть он работает по
принципу разделяй и властвуй это не из
не злой умысел просто все люди начинают
закрываться все люди начинают
страховаться и в этой в этот момент
когда все люди закрываются страхуется и
так далее гуру давайте будем
благородными и так далее хорошо звучит
но по факту же никто этого не делает и
более того тот кто вот будет вот это
такой я называю беззаботно оптимист
пострадает первий больше всего во время
криц поэтому лучше быть трусливым
параноиком в это время поэтому я лично
запасы продуктов узел продуктов питания
увидел гречку в том числе кто слушать
многими движений просто покупает
корзина на крыше кто-то на обмен это
предмет
но это уже как становится валюта в 90-е
годы это была водка валюты закупали
водку ее всегда можно поменять хоть
почту у нас просто счет ген остался
после 90
ведет тебя так я вам скажу так это не
наш ген у американцев будут тоже самое
когда и если помните ураган катрина
мародерство что было мародер очереди за
продуктами питания все люди на
средневековые уровень опускается
моментально культура слетает в культура
слетает мне нравится регресс идет
быстрее чем прогресс это потому что есть
называют закона симметрии добра и зла
для того чтобы сделать добро тебе нужна
энергия для того чтобы делать зло тебе
блага и не нашему может очень идет за то
же самое для того чтобы жить тебе нужна
энергия для того чтобы умереть в энергии
не нужно то есть чтобы деградирует
энергии нужно ты под горку подборку
спускаться всегда ли кому то есть
скатываться деградировать спится там на
диване валяться и так далее на самом
деле когда все началось наверное у всех
была одинакова во всех одинаковые
действие что все начали делать все
начали просто изучать этот контент со
всех сторон до сколько каналов там было
сколько новостей его даже есть синдром
когда происходит подобного плана
какие-то события что делаем мы
погружаемся очень сильно и глубоко туда
что влияет на вот это ментальное
здоровье когда ты не можешь работать но
я даже помню первые три дня мы приходили
на работу что делали мы обсуждали что
произошло мире не хотелось работать и
даже не мы не понимали зачем работать
когда из страх реально то есть ты
переживаешь особенно январский события
помните когда мы все изучали даже есть
вот этот синдром я начал смотреть на
себя как на руководителям потому что от
руководителя зависит все работает твой
команда эффективно или неэффективно я
смотрю течение делa неэффективно потому
что что я делаю я просто изучаю эти все
новости там какие-то видео смотреть
видео пересылают другим то есть чтобы у
них тоже этот был странствовать по факту
все мы делаем что мы посылаем вот этот
страх каждому я начал понимать то что
зачем я это сейчас изучаю когда по факту
начали все страдать и вот здесь как раз
таки есть ответственность на очень
правильная за команду за коллегами
начали понимать что сейчас нужно делать
и начали предпринимать кита решения
первое что сделаю такое ну хорошо самое
важное там родители да то есть они
купили продукты гречка почему- гречка
потому что это такой правду который не
портится поможет долго там хранится не
знаю там годами на самом деле и не
порция родители взяли все успокоили
погнали дальше поехали по первым
клиентом который есть клиенты которые
нам отказали но уже в работе вот такие
хорошо и вы начали думать о давай
работать с теми клиентами color на самом
деле кризис не коснулся или коснулся но
не так то есть мы там перешли на одних
блогеров вы перешли там на других
клиентов и так далее и вот здесь очень
важно содержать это ментальное здоровье
я начал думать что мне дает энергию
однозначно спорт и языки то есть если
никогда раньше у меня был такой дикой
мотивации изучает там английский язык да
с точки зрения там улучшения своего
разгар улучшения разговорной речи что
щас дому самое идеальное время чтобы
приступить потому что я помню и даже
сейчас открылись реально крутые
возможности для многих игроков и сферы
айти аналитики дизайна потому что от в
европе до идет русофоб то есть на самом
деле очень большой большая аудитория кто
работал в акте войти компания фрилансеры
их просто уволили уволили
буквально за 23 дня и сейчас они но
самцы жена класса не так сильно как бы
поменяли и вот рынок на самом деле
освободился очень многие мои знакомые
сейчас даже переезжают там чуть будем на
пмж
за шикарного фира потому что наверно у
моего у моего и наверное аудитории дал
моей аудитории есть мечта это получать
прибыль в долларах то есть не в той
валюте а вот и как раз таки для многих
сейчас появилось некое возьму сейчас
реально многие скупают курсы там пою
моих дизайнов по программированию дай то
есть вот сейчас то самое время когда
надо учиться то есть я сам смотрю
довольно новый момент и совпадают тот
случай который антикризисные образование
это дико рисовать чтобы согласно даже
сейчас на моих курсах актёрского
мастерства я вижу что очень много
бизнесменов которые сейчас пытается
поменять свой образ мышления это первое
второе они пытаются найти себя через
актерское мастерство и 3 они говорят мы
и готовы к новому ну вот смотрите что
происходит во время кризиса я до этого
говорил что во время кризиса сам кризис
что такое причиной основная причина крис
это несоответствие представления о мире
той реальности которые есть и в
результаты идет разбалансировка всего и
все вдребезги те методы которые ты
раньше у тебя были успешны и если ты
будешь их продолжать они будут тебя
ухудшать ситуацию то есть они тебя не
помогают а усугубляют твою ситуацию в
этой ситуации что происходит в этой
ситуация первая реакция человека человек
теряется как так я до этого там делал
это и было нормально а тут получается я
делаю а мне хуже и хуже я это делала мне
хуже и хуже человек первая реакция на
кризис всегда он берет тайм-аут паузу и
замирает это первая реакция замирает он
еще не знает что делать поэтому
заморозка идет все их судьи поэтому во
время кризиса первую очередь урезает
рекламный бюджет замораживают рекламные
бюджеты замораживают инвестиционные
проекты замораживают любые вложения
лицом а рожать любую активность это
первая реакция любых людей организации
так далее дальше и вот здесь
психологический друг который я
сам лично применяю рекомендую я сам
когда война россии с украиной началась и
а 10 не только сидел в телеграме только
новости смотреть больше нечего не делал
не раз все так себе но отличие от всех
меня заключается в том что я знал что
это происходит всегда потому что и
кризис настолько эмоционально сильный
фактор что ты даже если ты будешь
работать другие не будут работать толком
твои работы то есть твоя эффективность
от этого не вырастет поэтому я взял дал
себе отпуск официальный от туз 10 дней я
сказала 10 дней я не буду заниматься
работой я разрешаю и позволяю себе
переживать
названиями все официально
понимаете в чем дело если это вы не
сделаете то вы будете переживать
постоянно и не можете врубиться в работа
а тут как бы 10 дней счетчик идет я тебе
позволю у меня не возникает чувство вины
и потому что я себе выписал официальный
отпуск на переживание 10 не переживал
смотрел все новости и так далее
следующий что сделал это чтобы вернуть
работоспособность и вернулся в работу
это начал заниматься организации помощи
украине то есть гуманитарная помощь мы
написали пас начали собирает вещи и
лекарства отправляет это и когда ты
начинаешь помогать тому кто тебе хуже
это тебе стимулирует потому что у тебя
появляется смысл потому что ради себя от
ему жопу не понять а для другого ну как
бы ты можешь потому что тому хуже и ты
начинаешь вот так в облигации постепенно
вовлекаешься в этот процесс поэтому
здесь вопрос такой что кризис это такое
время когда 1 человек или организация
замирает и
ничего не может делать в это время лучше
всего дать официальный отпуск или
разрешению себе ничего не делать и
переживать
не винить себя не обвинять себя ничего
вот все после как проходит этот период
берете маленькие простые дела и
желательно начинают с помощью другим
людям которые
хуже
вот это вот это очень важно и потом
смотрите я еще что для себя я выработал
таза всего такую практику
она называется во времена кризиса
во-первых надо сгруппироваться
во вторых
нужно уметь что во время кризиса это
авто и в третьих надо стать ближе руки
от 3 вещь
если взять ну когда ты падаешь с любой
высоты то обязательно нужно
сгруппироваться что такое
сгруппироваться сгруппироваться это
значит перевести перевести всем ручное
управление
взять все под контроль
под контроль финансы под контроль там
расходы и доходы и так далее то есть
группировать сгруппироваться и значит
отказаться от лишних арендных платежей
отказаться от личных расходов от
кредитов от менее прибыльных товаров или
услуг оставить себе только прямыми
остального вся отказаться то есть
сгруппироваться дальше второй момент
надо стать маленьким потому что когда
падаешь на чем меньше тем меньше ущерба
когда рынок проходит дно надо
становиться максимально большим для
этого люди берут кредиты его максимально
в испуге используют рычаг но до того как
ты до дна не дошел не надо остановить
надо быть маленьким надо чем меньше тем
меньше ущерба ты получишь пошел такой
маленький это значит сокращать
производство сокращать офис сокращать
персонал section меня минимизируется
сокращать свои операции и так далее это
второй момент
третье это становиться близоруки
близоруки это значит не строит планы на
5 10 лет вперед не заглядывать вперед не
думать ни прогнозировать ничего
заниматься вот то что на расстояние
вытянутой руки короткие быстрые самое
главное проекты которые ты можешь
закончить вот в обозримом горизонте
вот сегодня означал в через неделю
закончил недельные десятидневный проект
это я называю стать близоруки и
четвертый момент это уже помимо этого
это почему спрос на образование идет
люди понимают что их представление о
реальности была другая реальность другая
они начинают искать различные способы
совпасть чтобы их взгляды начали
совпадать с реальностью поэтому он
происходит всякие чудеса бизнесмены
начинает заниматься актерским
мастерством
начинают занимать ораторский начинает
заниматься и ездит на голо обращается
гадалкам обращается гороскопом
по-разному это не только бизнесмены все
люди потеряны и все хотят быстро
восстановить свою связь с реальностью а
для восстановить связь с реальностью они
открыты для нового они готовы изучать
новый лишь бы лишь бы это помогло ищут
новые инструменты взаимодействия с
реальностью и так далее поэтому в это
время возрастает спрос на всякие
обучение практики в это время вы будете
получать совсем необычных клиентов
вообще вы говорите же по поводу
масштабирования да вообще мы допустим
вот во время кризиса мы сделали три вещи
которые я думаю ну хорошо очень влияют
нас мы во-первых перешли с режима
масштабирования в режим оптимизации то
есть абсолютно все мы начали сокращать
как на это сделали во первых я считаю во
время кризиса это идеальное время чтобы
внедрять катин технологий потому что
казнь технологии но это же об
эффективности то есть все процессы
должно быть эффективной неэффективные
процессы они автоматически отмирают то
есть и такой закон первое работает мы мы
перенесли вот производство своего
получается стук в турцию и у нас было
там очень много фирм прокладок хорошее
время мы мы как-то на это временно не
обращали внимание но как бы работаем
работаем а сейчас мы получается
перенесли туда все наши весь фокус и как
бы убрали эти фирмы по прокладке и мы
теперь закупаем по заводской цене как бы
так и получается мы вот этот вера харти
0 до в лирах это первое что мы сделали
вот оптимизировали все и
второй шаг я думаю мы сделали
ну искать как бы
прибыль доходы в долларах на люке мы это
второй шаг как сделать мы открытом
оптовую компанию который продает в
долларах то есть другим странам там
городским
африке и так далее это второй шаг что мы
сделали потому что ну вот эта
девальвация постоянно влияет и мы хотели
вот нивелирует вот эти вот риски
девальвационное до
этого предприняли двадцатом году для
себя решил я так двадцатым стал таким
так тоже руководителям я понял что нужно
объединять как я сам для себя решил я
как отдельные человек у которого есть
какой-то персонал преподаватели и так
далее мы будем что я вижу что из другие
такие же школы я понял что мы не выживем
по одним и я предложила почему если
допустим вас нет актерского мастерства
почему мы не объединимся вы будете свое
делать я буду свое но при этом мы будем
друг помогать взаимопомощи таким образом
мы пережили двадцатый год потом я понял
что эта система работает это объединение
и мы начали я предложил другой компании
мы с ними обидели теперь у меня две
точки в алмате где мы сосуществуем как
этот животном мире до годами маленький
экосистема сада это реально помогает
объединяться и это все но это где-то у
нас есть что мы не можем попросим что мы
можем помочь друг другу надо всегда
смотри и тоже всегда делается заработка
на противоходе и я же говорил крис
управляет людьми через разделение
как и и политики разделяй и властвуй это
закон кризиса он хочет разделить людей а
если хочешь преуспеть во время кризиса
ты должен наоборот объединяться в этом
плане у меня есть три вещи когда меня
спрашивают куда инвестировать во время
кризиса видно игру во первых среда -
нужно смотреть на стадию кризиса на этой
стадии нельзя инвестировать но есть 3
вещи которые надо инвестирует в любой
стадии на любой стадии кризиса первое
это на изменение своего мышления вот
сегодня ходишь говорю про мышление идея
такая что на изменение свое мышление
фонишь говорим насчет эмоциональное
состояние что эмоциональное состояние
влияет на поведение человека абсолютно
правильно но что влияет на эмоциональное
состояние на эмоциональное состояние
обливает влияет мировоззрение влиять
мировоззрение
от что формирует мировоззрение
мировоззрение формирует 7 вещей это
воспитание с детства это образование и
самообразование
дальше эта среда
дальше эта культура
дальше это
[музыка]
источники информации
дальше это его собственный опыт вот это
все и но образование и самообразование
две разные вот вот это все семь вещей
она влияет на мировоззрение и здесь
вопрос такой что
когда я говорю что
как воспринимает кризис и куда
инвестировать первую очередь надо
инвестировать в те направления или курсы
или направлений книги или даже фильмы
хороший фильм это тоже инвестиция
которая будет меняет ваше мировоззрение
потому что изменится ваше мировоззрение
и имеется ваше отношение к ситуации
изменится ваше отношение к ситуации
изменится ваше поведение поэтому первый
источник направления или инвестиции это
инвестиции направленные на изменение
вашего мировоззрения инвестиции в себя
до по сути второе
которые я рекомендую всеми mister
независимо от стадии крис это инвестиции
в среду среда именно среда общения среда
поддержки общения вот то что о чем ты
говорил вступайте в это время в
ассоциации в клубы и форумы и
конференции надо больше общения потому
что кризис хочет на astra детьми а мы
должны объединяться или чтобы преуспеть
если начнем это прятаться по норкам топ
хуже будет всем я в судах харли купцы
поэтому во время кризиса harley кушелев
это классная потому что смотрите мужчина
должен дотащить человек должен сидеть
как паук на паутине вот это бизнес вот
эта семья вот эта дружба вот это хобби и
так далее 1 2 паутина порвались он
должен у его уровень не должен упасть и
вот самооценка сама уже не должна упасть
чтобы остановиться одно обвинить
восстановить можно а если ты полностью
посвящен только бизнесу у тебя это
порвалась ни с кем больше не общаешься
всего три колибри стужи да поэтому очень
важно второе направление это инвестирует
в среду это независимо от стадии бизнеса
и
третье направление третье направление
который я великим я рекомендую
инвестировать на любой стадии кризиса
это путешествие
путешествие почему потому что
путешествие меняет мировоззрение человек
путешествие отрывает человека от той
среды в которой он сидит и переживает и
так далее
путешествие во время кризиса становится
дешевле
делать плюс во время путешествия
появляются новые связи новые люди новые
знакомства и так далее и плюс
путешествует и дает во время о пережить
в этот эмоциональный период когда рынок
падает вот в зарождение кризисы развития
и это ускорение вот эти две фазы
особенно если ты уехал путешествие то с
мимо тебя это все пролетела когда мимо
те
при условии что ты уже успел
конвертируются в доллары не переживаешь
там и нибудь там за границей и
путешествие в это время это очень
хороший это необязательно за границей
можно уехать степь в горы и так далее
тем более вы когда я рынок рос вы без
устали пахали 24 на 7
2 3 года не были в отпуске вот как раз
возьмите отпуск и это на стадии да пока
рынок пока крис не пойдет к замедлению
их дну до этого момента лучше ничего не
делать это тот случай когда вот
пассивность важнее активность а как
вообще насчет переезда во что вы скажете
вот многие люди сейчас задумываться же
переезжать там допустим с казахстана я
только положительно с одной точки зрения
это меняет а мировоззрение потому что
новая среда формирует новые навыки
нового мировоззрения ты понимаешь о
оказывается не все как у нас здесь
турции все по-другому и ты начинаешь
обучаться новым спился второе ты
формируешь новую среду у тебя появятся
новые знакомства новые связи не новые
друзья и ты понимаешь блин то что мы в
казахстане там считаем кризисом
оказываем не такой страшный крыс порция
это по-другому воспринимается понимаешь
. сиденья меняет точку зрения есть такое
правило . сиденья меняет точку зрения
вот я здесь сижу у меня один вид с твоей
позиции в любой с 23 если тысяч до
гарета один бит внизу другой вид .
сиденья определяет точку зрения и
поэтому начинать надо вот смотри когда
корж то бишь надо
управлять своим состоянием и
эмоциональным им невозможно управлять и
можно прыгать через немирова дренаж
потому что эмоциями мне потому что часто
задают вопрос а как вот не гневаться как
погашать злость я говорит не возможно
это лучина как тогда я гуру есть три
инструмента риск-менеджмента первое
избегайте рисков 2 страхует риски и
четвертое в минимизируете посредстве
риск поэтому я знаю где например на
каких позициях я перехожу на эмоции
условно там религиозно тему словно
поэтому в только спор за ход за религию
я либо ухожу гибриды давайте мы в этом
не специалисты не буковой то есть лучше
избегать ситуаций либо второй момент
раньше там давно по молодости когда я
пил я любил все дело до конца и я пил и
очень много и при этом очень много и на
дурно шутил бурно шутил я могу кого-то
обидеть предметом начала сразу был
ребята если я выпью от дурной
до назад припомнить не буду поэтому а
игра все что я так как завтра не буду
помнить что я вас обидел я не хочу чтобы
наши отношения использовать испортились
я ценю отношения с вами и у меня принять
такое все что я не помню того не было
поэтому завтра я не буду помнить я буду
думать что этого не было а вы будете
ходить на меня курсе стоит обижать
поэтому заранее приношу свои извинения
во первых а не поить и меня не наливайте
не подбадривайте не там никакой камбий
до конца и тогда здоровья третьих весь я
ночну вести
неадекват вы знаете это не я это
последствия того что вы меня споили
поэтому а не поймите меня 2 если напоите
не обижайтесь это не я на завтра я вас
прощение не буду просить потому что я не
помню поэтому заранее приношу извинение
то есть это называется
минимизация по столице и минимизация
последствия либо когда ты идёшь на
вечеринку знать что тебя могут напоить
либо ты сам можешь выпить ты сразу ключ
от машина bosch водитель ты говоришь ни
в коем случае не не даже как бы этим не
приказывал чтобы и не делал все это
называется страхование риск это ты
знаешь что идешь частного рисковую
территорию и можешь потом взять водитель
ключей говорит и гарцевать при заранее
инструкции jyj водителя и все ты
застраховался все либо вообще отдал
машину приехала на такси ты
застраховался вот три способа управления
резким риском и
нужно всегда это в голове иметь в виду и
кризис когда происходит это тот случай
когда хуан что хорошо сказал что
кризис
вот когда ты агаш одеты для тебя мороз
не такой чувствительной у меня по этому
поводу есть такая вещь я размышлял по
поводу знаете в китайском языке есть
иероглиф который обозначает кризис но
все новерна знают который говорит этот
иероглиф обозначается одной стороны
опасность риски и опасности с другой
стороны обозначает возможность я подумал
китайцы не могли же они же не дураки
взять один мир облив дать вот этим там
назначение с какого момента опасность
превращается в возможностям я понял две
вещи первая зависимости от стадии то
есть на стадии зарождения развития и усы
ускорение
этот иероглиф только опасность и риск а
на стадии замедление дно этой рублёв
превращается в возможность
это той зависимости от стадий то есть
вот это когда опасности риска когда
возможность зависит от стадии
это кризиса это первый второй момент я
понял зависит от твоей подготовленности
если ты готов the credit людям
возможность если ты не готов тот кризис
для тебя всегда опасность и риск тот
случай когда про одежду если ты тепло
одет сибиряк говорит не тот кто не
мерзнут а тот кто тепло одевается а вот
этот вот есть какой-то индикатор там вот
вот допустим когда он переходит в стадию
возможности какие индикаторы на
некоторые замедления замедления когда
все люди уже смотри даже посмотреть сми
вот сейчас почему у эта стадия
зарождения потому что все обсуждают и
говорят открылись но это как и наш
неуловимый джо все о нём говорят но
никто его не видел пока жестко люди на
себе это не прочувствовали еще в россии
может уже начали чувствовать но я считаю
так смотрите санкции в виде в марте в
начале марта начале войны санкции мы
знаем что у любого предприятия есть
склад готовой продукции
есть продукция в производстве есть склад
сырья то есть есть склад сырья в
продукция в производстве или склад
готовой продукции это как мы им укажем
предприятие полтора двухмесячный запас
дальше есть магазины или
распределительном центре у них тоже есть
склады это еще на полмесяца меню полный
смесь то есть до того пока санкции
ударят по простому россиянину должно
обратить 220 в месяц поэтому я ожидаю
что эффектах и будет только в мае
будет только в мае и сейчас стадия
развития кризиса то есть все люди
говорят что это такое что будет какое
будет глубок не благу глубокий как долго
он будет идти и так далее во время разве
и стадий развития кризиса все о нём
говорят
но еще толком никто не почувствовал
конкретные последствия на стадии
ускорения люди начинают чувствовать
потенция и сразу начинает корректирует
свое поведение но уже а кризисе мало
говорят
люди больше действуют за действенным на
стадии замедления люди уже говорят о
других вещах но там индикатор другой
меньше плохих новостей поступает то есть
люди как бы превратились нет не то что
ситуация она же любая плохая ситуации
может включаться вечно просто ухудшение
ситуации она не может ухудшаться
постоянно и
и вот этот кризис становится нормой люди
уже привыкает что это
многие люди даже не воспринимаем его не
воспринимает как рис они воспринимают
как просто уже новая норма потому что в
это время появляется новая волна
бизнесмена в которой мы жили в других
услугах для них это уже вообще норм а
потому что на стадии замедления рынок
начинает покрыть начинает рождать новые
возможности на новые возможности как
правило клюют не старые бизнесмены она
выведится
и для них это
не кризис это нормально нормальная
ситуация только зарождается потому что
открывается новые ниши новые
специальности новой профессии а вот на
дне уже потенциал плохих новостей
исчерпан больше поступает либо
нейтральность либо хороших новостей и
люди начинают автоматически мечтать
вот накоплю кучу машину при надо бы на
грани связи и в на на стадии дна люди
начинают вспоминать докризисные времена
с ностальгией на 100 лет а когда ты
вспоминаешь с приятным таким чувством ну
как сейчас вспоминает с горечью блин
типа блину было же так классно может
чуток монах мин было там видно вот
тогда а там уже будет с ностальгией то
есть за 1 год
19 вспоминают но вот факт то что вот
появляясь только на сергей вот эта
стадия 1 уже плохие новости не поступает
практически контроля коронавирус да люди
смирились
люди уже бесстыдно но опять беспечны
короли между последней часть корми
версии посмотри уже маски во-первых у
каждого в кармане маска это норма
макароны вирусов уже много не говорят
уже новости про коронавирус уже никого
не возбуждает и это неинтересно
соответственно просто перестает печатай
прокормить у каждого при этом в кармане
на маска при этом каждый охранник на
заведение уже не так жёстко требует эту
маску ты сама делаешь
возможность снять в этом мы прошли но
прошли от начала этого заболела
говорили то что в этом году огромность 6
6 тысяч каждый молила прошлом году у
кота болела в день там подвисывайтесь у
нас к закрывали все и был унесен ужасное
лекарстве fatal а потом буду 6000 болел
вот смотри - причем на смотрите под этим
вы возьмете графе коронавируса там была
там несколько пиков очень высоких но
хоть пики заболеваемости были очень
высокие одинаковые но эмоционально
восприятия последних пиков было такое
хотя пока рестарта по количеству
заболеваем их хотя он такой же как
первые пике но восприятие людьми уже
этих пиков найти как ну да и у кого-то
уже заболел удивишь ну да там кто-то
начал надеясь на всевышнего кто-то на
авось кто-то на свое везение кто-то
называем приветствую все это уже дну
пройдено то есть наши же эмоции тоже не
могут на одно на один триггер долга
реагировать раз всплеск порождается в
реакция бей беги беги беги к кросби и
так его злость агрессия о беге и когда
ты начинаешь резко там чего то делать
там конвертировать что-то это резкий
движение создавать и
все это дальше начинает эмоции в
неизбежно только подай проблема
большинства людей в том что особенно те
кто кризис первый раз
переживает
одна проблема шапка законодательства
думает ну сейчас это тоже пройдет мы
коронавирус встретили тоже дам да это
там центру беспечно а потом когда начали
умирать люди сотнями там и поэтому мы на
самом деле пришли страх нас догнал когда
последствия мы увидели в начале люди
одна категория людей беспечно и они
думают шапка закидать ильский ничего
переживем ничего страшно мы же молодые
приспособимся человек переоценивать свои
возможности и недооценивает угрозы риска
также как лавина маленькие камушки
сыпаться да ладно там что ты обращаешь
внимание к муж лежит там то есть они
видели человек что идет пласт весь
сейчас скатывается да ладно это же два
три камушка чего ты будешь да ладно
пошли по этой тропе гея какая тропинка
валить надо отсюда быстрее ты чё блин
понимаете вот и вот это вот эта
инерционность человеческой психологии
что
да не переживем не такие кризисы
переживают да ничего страшного да пока
нормально же там так далее вот это губит
людей
поэтому я просто знаю я там много
занимаясь экстремальными видами спорта
путешествие тогда бедная и читал много
статистики и так как его авиации пилот
все-таки статистиков почему умирают люди
и в основном люди умирают от двух вещей
первое от паники
то есть не от самого холода голода и так
далее умирают в основном от паники и
второе от шапка закидать ильского
отношения недооценки опасности от
недооценки от двух вещей умирает от
паники и недооценки опасности я почему
всем говорю
конвертируйте делать это делайте это и
так далее потому что моя главная цель
это для того чтобы вы выжили потому что
чтобы достичь успеха и отговорил надо
долго оставаться в игре как можно дольше
оставаться в игре а потом уже думать как
победить в китайский трактате о войне из
функций там говорится две вещи этот
конфуции говорит
в этом он говорит так что
непобедимость заключена в тебе саму
возможность победой заключена в твоем
враги
хоть ты должен сначала обеспечить свою
непобедимость только вот он возможно
победа но при этом не победим из зависит
от тебя а возможность победа зависит от
кризиса то есть сначала обеспечиваю
выживаемость а потом думай как победить
кризис
мы в принципе неплохо сегодня поговорили
хорошая
беседа я надеюсь что я не превратил
передачу монолог да нет не всегда
комплекс неполноценности вот в этом
плане я болтун жесткий болтон это
признаю приношу извинения люблю
поговорить как любой указах которым руки
попадает микрофон катастрофы
значит я еду мне такую вещь на любом
твои катастрофа есть и
какому-то казаху попадает микрофон и
еще хуже катастрофы почти идеями штор
месте этот казах еще в возрасте но чем
дальше
эти
два компонента сошлись я в возрасте мне
это это просто катастрофа поэтому мелочи
микрофон не давать но надеюсь мои
налоги и то польза быть на самом деле
очень интересно было с вами пообщаться
посмотреть у кого что случилось и какой
сами восприняли крис сейчас у нас такой
свободный микрофон если угодно и все
дела но если ты думаешь что с тобой это
не случится с тобой а потому что про
когда я помню когда коронавирус носился
а все начали закупаться магазины ходить
мы супруга и вообще никуда не пошли она
только хотела с америки и мы заезжаем
квартиру домой и утром хотим пойти на
прогулку и стоят полицейские и не
пускают таки назад запуске что они такие
взойдите зайдите еще годам о музыке что
происходит в общем чате смотра все наш
дом закрыли первые дома который открыли
это она же так а потом нам давали
подачки там родители попросили друзей
чтобы мясо привезли первый дом который
закрыт к был наш теперь когда ситуация
была 5 января мы супруга такие вот
сейчас мы отдохнем иммунал билет на
мальдивы это вообще история все только
только все начинается мы звоним там
нашему водителю чтобы он отвез в
аеропорт поехали даже пораньше чтобы не
дождаться пока все стемнеет уехали из
вадим всем друзьям типа как все это
переживает переживает морган калязин
типа чё делаешь
интернет есть и огне интернет нет я
сейчас собираюсь вылетает буквально
остается два часа иди забегает мародер в
аэропорт через 3 часа я уже сижу дома то
есть никуда не уехала к под как раз таки
понимания того что с тобой это не
случится а я думаю что этого не случится
по любому это случится значит ты
правильную тему за делаешь его во время
всего и пандемии я знал что я сто
процентов за более и я ездил во все
формы конференции в турция украина
россия казахстан где только не уступал
когда стану узбекистан и там 1000 2 3
человек тысяч человек или после
выступления все вот так вы правы
подходит им и здоровье фоткаемся дорогу
и все ко мне подходит я как это
полицейский картонный стою со всеми все
пытаются обнять меня я думал топот их
заболеть не западал не заболел а потом в
конце думаю не надо на килиманджаро идти
последнего месяца последовали за нельзя
болеть надо себя поберечь
прямо перед вылетом на килиманджаро за
два дня я сдаю пациент не льют у вас tcr
позитивный я заболел карно вирусу вот
это вообще я у меня есть такое правило
чем больше до чего-то хочет тем меньше
шансов что длина получишь это первое
правило второе правило крис всегда бьет
тебя по самым твоим слабым местам по
самым болевым местам и по самым местам
где ты не желаешь три вещи куда бьет
крис там где слабо там где наиболее
больно и там где ты не ожидаешь поэтому
лучше сами прикиньте в голове что у вас
слабые где у вас больнее всего и где вы
меньше всего ожидаете и прикрывайте
именно титулы в актерском мастерстве
есть такое правило не знать что дальше
хотя ты знаешь что у тебя сценарии ты
знаешь всех героев когда-то на сцене
когда ты перед камерой есть правило не
знать что дальше это сейчас конкретно
живут этим правилам я понимаю что есть
кризис я понимаю что будет пример но для
себя я говорю я не знаю что будет дальше
мы при этом пытаясь как-то шаг за шагом
к этому если его опять к актерскому
царство нам помогать ты знаешь это не
они не то что актерское мастерство
я изучаю
можно так с законы жизни я вообще
позиционируется как исследовать берешь
любую сферу боевые искусства
пилотирования бизнес актёрское
мастерство в любом деле если ты
совершенствуешь это ты в конечном итоге
приходишь к одним и тем же законам и
принципам к одним и тем же джеки чан су
и время сказал хотите быть великими
занимайтесь долго одним делом
я бизнесменом часто я говорю самое
главное долго оставаться в игре в твоем
случае когда ты говоришь не ожидать
ничего не ждать это тоже как один из
способов кризис-менеджмент
то есть ты или в тот же
бусидо из-за термины и в траве в листве
называется книга самурая где он говорит
я не знаю кто будет моим врагом вы есть
и я буду познаю себя там не неважно кто
будет мой враг
потому что до того как ты
должен прийти в состояние не знаю что
будет ты должен сначала отточить свое
мастерство
потому что если ты ничего не умеешь и
живешь по принципу не знаю что будет топ
закончится бедой потому что уоррен
баффет сказал так на рынке существует
всего два самых главных кризиса 1 когда
человек не ведает что творит а второе
когда он не знает и не понимает что он
не ведает что творится в твоем случае
когда ты профессиональный актер в
профессии и ты идешь общая канва
сценарии есть но ты идешь в потоке или
там в в общем понимает твоя задача
передать образ они concrete куда
тогда тогда конечно но ты ты-то
подготовлен я к этому и говорю ты
понимаешь что тебя ждет на третьем ты
для себя от этого из своей психологии
психики да как такое хоп сосуд на оверах
у меня правило не бойся божатся даю себе
всегда возможность обожать справа
правосторонний значит а дальше и третье
есть тоже актерское правило что если
части на себя примеряешь
одежду и не знаю жизнь другого человека
а что если я бизнесмен что если я там
еще кто то что если и вот это тоже
помогает и вроде как и ты но при этом
немножко абстрагироваться и твои мысли
переключается это очень круто а ты
знаешь в актерском матери мастерстве как
ни у кого наверно другой работы-то
развитое это очень хорошее качество
многие люди не умеют взглянуть на себя
со стороны и
соответственно и не могут прочувствовать
что чувствует другой человек или что
человек другой человек думает особенно
это важно когда одна посмотреть на себя
со стороны и вот отвертка мастерстве то
оттачивают этой медитации вот это навык
на самом деле очень крутой очень крутой
увидеть себя со стороны это очень крутой
это знаешь как как например тот же навык
когда ты даешь первое интервью а потом
тебе не нравится не свой вид не свой
голос у тебя такой диссонанс потому что
ты провел свой голос слышать изнутри
совсем по-другому звучит напрямую есть
да да и другие существа по-другому у
актера более адекватно реальная картинка
самом себе потому что он выходит из себя
и потом вы знаете есть интересный такой
момент во время обучения
так как и обучения много занимаемся
читаю есть
два таких способа обучения вообще
свойство любого человека когда он
чего-то встречает сопротивляться но он
охраняет свои границы и сопротивляется
это свойство любого человека и когда ты
приходит человек и начинаешь что-то
хочешь ему объяснить 1 его реакция это
возразить его мысленно готовит
контраргументы это ты даже ему хорошие
вещи говорить а он он сразу оборона
переходит это реакция бей беги реакцию
он чего сразу оценивает ты его
критикуешь подкалываешь или чё или а
хочешь обмануть или что потому что из
этой асимметрии добра и зла я которое
говорил прежде всего он начинает думать
негативную сторону все это меня хочет
обмануть либо унизить либо при кого-то
надо мной либо это последнюю очередь то
он думает о вдруг вам не хочешь пользу
приносите соответственно первая реакция
защититься и проблемы образования когда
ты начинаешь человеку говорить советы
счета хорошая говорит человек это не
воспринимает потому что у него стоит
защитная пленка барьер и
как его как можно я думал как можно
обойти этот защитный барьер как можно
защитным барьером для того чтобы обойти
защиту защитный барьер нужно поставить
человека в такую ситуацию при котором он
сам принимает решение и для этого
идеально подходит две вещи первая это
игры второе это от . актерское
мастерство
ну актерством мастерство нужно до игр то
есть мы делаем настольную игру
условно монополию и мы играем и
в результате или игра мафия или разные
шляпы из когда роли разные годами и я
тени объясняю что санжар мне очень
херово когда ты про меня так говорили да
да да ты ты защищаешься типа я норман я
хорошо от под уме шляпу мою тебе одеваю
и начинаю вести так как ты камень и ко
мне и я не надо мне тебе объяснять ты
понимаешь как херово оказывается
маргулан ты понимаешь поэтому актёрское
мастерство
помогает обойти
защитный барьер и научить человеку
человек когда ты ж таки пословицы
английская пословица есть прежде чем
кого-то обучили походил его обуви
но походи в его обуви это значит побудь
актер только может переживать чужую
жизнь чужую роль и благодаря этому он
больше понимает что другие могут думать
о тебе и
второе это игры когда тебя помещают в
ситуации игры ты так
вот ты например в расти и адам бер
говорю давайте сегодня мы играем ты
сегодня будешь работать
уборщиком в офисе у себя вовсе нет ты
такой целый день ну это же
целый день
ты целый день в уборщиком поработал и ты
начинаешь понимать состоянии уборщик он
будет от это боссы запарили poland ссоре
там уходит в грязную обуви вещах в мире
и все за уборка никто не следит за чем
они вещи туда оставляют все другие мысли
приходят и ты начинаешь уборщика хорошо
понимать а
если вы можете придет тебе на счету
сказать дамир у нас неправильно надо
сделать вот так довольно ты скажи и я
шеф я знаю лучше понимать и вот это
иллюзия руководители в том что они знают
лучше своих подчиненных как бы считается
вот такая же вертикаль я начальник и
дурак вот эта большая иллюзия и если ты
придешь начальнику объяснять это первая
его реакция он будет защита и контратак
и
соответственно как вот человек такого
объяснить два способа дуга sky давай
сыграем роли станем актёрами либо второе
давать играем в игру вот поэтому я пить
и
даже вот это как раз таки проходили
игрушкой вот недавно у нас было алексей
нам этот рассказал крутая очередь фишка
играми на он выстроил игр в minaj и
определяет конкретно качество людей это
это крутая игра надо посмотреть что игра
очень эти вот день и денежно патолог
монополия между тоже очень крутые глянь
и показывает у меня кровь игры это ключ
ко всем игра идут средства на чему дети
быстрее обучаются всему языка на какие
growing потому что игры игры тебя
заставили заставляют что-либо серьёзно
воспринимать ты можешь облажаться и тебе
интересно 4 3 фактора которые мы теряем
со временем добра стоим вот эти каким-то
взрослый толку стальной подумает а вы
мне что-то плохо вот и дураки не могу
это сделать тогда алекс толпу сын
архивирования и вот надо нам немножко
тоже учится у них это кризис как раз то
самое время когда
мы плавно переходим концу наши подкасты
самое то самое время когда больше
играйте
боль выкидываете ведь все свои оперение
и статус чем быстрее мы это сделаем тем
быстрее будущего быть реальность вы
должны четко понимать что реальность это
земля ближе к земле земля дает силу чем
ближе бы и ниже тем быстрее обретете
силу быстрее обретете уверенность
поэтому выкидывать все свои статусы и
все свои регалии медали и так далее
кризис обнуляется и говорит те методы к
благодаря которым ты дала достигать их
медалей нынче не работаю нынче не
работать поэтому етом причем во всех
сферах жизни месяц вы сейчас ты вот часы
сена пишет поэму про назарбаева то
наверняка ты не будешь
три года назад
распланировать
америку поменяет волчата своим
я продолжаю писать ему фамилию поднять
просто и терпит
суть такая что кризис именно то время
когда нужно а всячески находить связь с
реальностью и это очень сильно помогает
делать игры поэтому будьте несерьезными
я в этом плане я рекомендую делаете
много пробных пилотных проектов смотрите
по сторонам на 360 градусов кризис
всегда плохо бьет по
узкоспециализированным специалистам и
компаниям которые специализируются на
одном
рынке поэтому надо кризис он поощряет
многостаночники специалистов широкого
профиля людей которые готовы браться за
любую работу и изучать все вокруг
поэтому делайте много пилотов для этого
отбросить свои статусы играйте
экспериментируйте пробуйте и желаю вам
всем успехов и удачи прожить эти
нелегкие времена ваше пожелание
смотрите если раньше экспертом
предпринимателям начинающим
предпринимателям чтобы быть
конкурентоспособным нужно было бежать
все равно нельзя было сидеть нужно было
бежать то сейчас в нынешнее время чтобы
быть конкурентоспособным нужно бежать
еще быстрее то есть еще быть вот как
буквально померил засучив рукава
начинать приступать к реальным месте вот
самое главное мира всем нам и качайте
лично там жертвой 2 рекомендации или
пожеланий я наверное 5 с точки зрения
психологии актерского мастерства не
загонять себя дайте себе возможность
облажаться но всегда держись в кармане
кулак на случай того что нужно будет
ощущаться на случай будьте готовы к симу
но сильно себя не перележать держите
кормила держите в кармане кулак звучало
как держите в кармане фигу
но иногда может это тоже надо
ну и ничто не говорило что сознание
который придумал проблема не множество
его решать я помню ровно та же уровне
поэтому
кресло песен что нужно делать больше но
если хочешь получить иной результат
нужно делать по-другому по-другому ты
можешь делать только в другом состоянии
ума или когда ты уже другой человек это
очень себя согласен что карлонар от тем
что нужно с мировоззрением я считаю что
еще хочешь получать результате легче чем
также легко как раньше во время кризиса
кризисе наверно уже адаптироваться
именно ментальная к этому
грубая сила наверно навредить мне
кажется nomer я бы хотел пожелать
того чтобы ну опять вот соглашусь с
анзором чтобы не париться потому что
любые кризиса они как приходили такие
уходят со временем но при этом нужно
быть готовым
имейте ввиду что бывают разные концы но
при этом не париться какой-то такой
совет
речь пошла здоровым пофигизме я так
считаю что на этой стадии на younow это
одно из важных тертый нужно
нужных лайфхаков дорог пофигизм до тех
пор пока мы не дойдем стадию замедление
для криса желаю вам всем благополучно
пережить эти условия кризиса этот кризис
главное не унывать и самое главное одной
из главных вещей никогда не теряйте веры
проблема еще многих людей в том что
когда кризис переходит стадию ускорение
большинства людей возникает ощущение что
все катастрофа все конец света и больше
никогда не будет ничего хорошего
отстранитесь посмотрите на всю ситуацию
со стороны по изучайте историю
посмотрите что в истории человечества
кризис и были похожи поэтому самое
главное любой ситуации не теряйте веры в
то что все в конце завершится
благополучно на этом заканчиваем спасибо
вам за ваши просмотры
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]